kate how are we doing just dandy how are
you
just dandy too just dandy i love that
all right so how can i help what's going
on um i'm calling to
ask for help navigating relationships
with my married siblings
all right so bring it on i'm 24
um and i'm the youngest of 10. most of
them
most of them are married and their
priorities as they should be are their
spouses and children um but i just get
in this pretty regular emotional battle
between
feeling kind of lost in the shuffle
worthless and significant
um just like always back of the line and
then just you know kind of suck it up
kids like this is what happens
everyone's supposed to grow up and have
their own families and you just have to
you know i guess just be prepared for
whatever comes your way um how old are
you
24 24 you told me that that's right so
you're 24
you've got 10 brothers and sisters how
old is the oldest one
um she would be 47
almost 48. 47 48 so she's was she a de
facto parent to you
yeah yeah she was 23 when i was born and
loved kids and
yeah i was kind of my second mom okay
and did you have a third mom and a
fourth mom too and a fifth mom probably
you know not really um mostly and i
i didn't even exist when the first four
of them graduated high school so um
wow okay yeah i you know i've
had fairly good relationships with a lot
of them but for most of them i don't
really
i don't really know them other than
husbands and wives and
mothers and fathers i don't really know
them as well as just my brothers and
sisters
so they're as much uncles and aunts as
they are brothers and sisters really huh
in some ways yeah so painting a picture
of what you wish was going on
what do you wish was happening
um i guess i just i want to be friends
like when i was growing up i just had
this
i always wanted to be big enough
whenever by the time i was in seventh
grade
i was the only one left in the house um
and i just i would watch home videos and
i just
wanted so badly to have been big enough
to just i guess experience life with
them instead of coming up on the tail
end and just
getting all the advice from the mistakes
and successes that they'd had and
um and that's not really a fair picture
it's not like they never did anything
with me but
um but i at this point i just kind of
feel like i'm
sliding into their lives whenever they
have a second because they're busy right
they've got
careers and families and um and i i'm
craving them just making time for me but
it's
not necessarily a fair ask but then i
just go into this tailspin
of of every little time that they say no
it's just like adding to this
list of rejection in my mind of you know
no you're not worth me taking away from
my family and i
don't want them to take away from their
family
and i guess that's where my my struggle
comes i just don't know how to
i guess reconcile those two emotions of
i'm proud of you for being
good spouses and parents and would never
want
you to be anything less but i also just
i don't want to feel
important enough yeah where where else
do you get rejected where else have you
been rejected
put your family aside where else do you
experience rejection
you experience rejection in school do
you get have rejection in your own
relationships or at work
not not really um i mean
it takes me like years to make friends
why is that at all
how come i i i really struggle with
spending time on relationships that i
don't see
being real
i guess or deep enough
so i i really just have a hard time just
going out to hang out with somebody if i
don't really
feel like they're going to be a really
true friend to me in the future
so you you called me can we go real can
we swan dive into the
into the deep waters for a minute um
why or where does
your judgment of your snap judgment of
you meet somebody you talk to them for a
few minutes and you immediately deem
you're not going to be someone that's
going to be worth my long term time and
you bail
where does that come from i have no idea
it's either a sense of superiority or
it's a sense
of fear of getting hurt at some point
which one do you think it is that might
be both um
yeah i mean i guess definitely both i
feel like i don't know if
i would necessarily say superiority but
i do get the
you know i have values and
things that i want to uphold and i i
know that i regularly feel like if
you're gonna
be trying to get me to not uphold those
values or if i feel like you're not
gonna be
um respectful of them then i struggle
with that a lot
um well as you should right those are
your values but
this is a little bit deeper when you
meet somebody and decide
you know what you're probably not going
to be someone who i'm going to have
long-term
experiences with that i'm not going to
we're probably not gonna connect
a couple of years from now so let's just
cut it off now that's a really great way
to keep you from getting hurt
relationally and it's a great way to
to keep you completely and totally alone
and so one of the greatest ways of never
getting hurt there is one surefire way
there's one surefire way of never
getting hurt and that's
never having really deep relationships
with people
never choosing to go into deep
relationships with people because the
one guarantee the price of admission for
being a good friend
the price of admission for falling in
love the price of admission for being a
connected family member
is hurt eventually something's going to
hurt
and there's something about you and i'm
trying to get it i want you to
walk me through this there's something
about you that
is fearful of getting hurt and it's
easier to be on the sidelines with the
built-in relationships that are innate
family and they need to be i'm feeling
this separation this gap
but also at the same time there's other
relationships that you could be
experiencing
that you have would enrich you that
would challenge you
and you just deem them on the front end
which protects you but also make sure
you're completely alone
yeah what are you worried about hurting
you
kate in san diego i guess
um i've always when i
when i do have friends i really only
have like a you know one or two
extremely good ones and everybody else
is just kind of there
and both times
oh they just kind of disappear
um i you know the first one i was my
best friend when i was a kid and
um we were best friends for years and
then
she went to a different school and then
i moved away the next year and she
literally just stopped talking to me
um and then
the next one when i was in high school
and then i went to college and
after about a year i heard started
happening her life and
she did the same thing almost and
recognized it and apologized later but i
guess they
are you a great friend
why i think so i hope so
from my perspective i would say yes but
that you're awesome
that's not a that's i'm not digging i'm
just wondering are you a great friend
yeah i i think i am yeah
and so what i want to tell you is you're
worth being 24 years old and have having
had more than just two good friends in
your lifetime
you are worth having i've got somebody
at my house
this week who i've known for 25 years
he's just crashing with us we think
differently
we live differently we act differently
we still relentlessly make fun of each
other
and we still relentlessly hold each
other accountable for
a core set of values
and he's one of a number of great
wonderful friendships that i've had that
fades and ebbs and flows
and is rich and is deep
but you're worth more than two
friendships and when it circles back to
your family
you're worth more than just hoping that
they will reach out and include you
you're worth including yourself you're
worth going to
their kids games and their kids events
and doing the things relationally
instead of sitting on the outside and
waiting for them to include you
you're a person of value enough that is
worth being around other people
your love is worth other people
experiencing
and that means risk relationships don't
start with comfort they start with risk
they start with hey will you be my
friend
or hey let's go hang out or man you're
weird or i don't like the way you say
that or
i don't like your language or or fill in
the blank but they all start with risk
right i think i think that's where i
struggle though because i do take those
risks
and i you know i am included in their
family lives but i'm
i'm asking my brother to come hang out
with me for
literally the first time just us in the
two years that i've lived near him
and the 10 years that i've
been anywhere near old enough to go hang
out and he can't take the time away from
his family
sure like dude three hours
and what does he say when you call him
um well is it too long two hour long
conversation of
really frustrating but it literally was
he's in the military they've got several
kids and he's
getting ready to play yeah um and so to
him
it was it literally it was a how dare
you put that on me
and can i tell you that i think that's
fair can i tell you i think that's fair
like everything in his life's about to
be upside down and
for sure what i would say is friendship
works two ways
brother and sisterhood works two ways
and you lift each other up when the
other person's down
and so instead of hey you owe me some
time together
it is you're about to deploy you're
about to be separated from your kids for
a year you're going to be in a situation
that you may or may not be safe
you're going to be away from your wife
i'm going to come insert myself and
start making meals
and mow your lawn and do groceries and
things like that
i've offered yeah well sometimes babysit
so that they can go spend time together
i offer to babysit so that she can go
have time alone because she's about to
be with them all day every day
just by herself and they don't take me
up on it
i i don't i i truly i don't know what
else
of myself i can give without
just feeling again like i'm just lost
like i'm just constantly
here to make everything easier for you
but when i'm
almost depressed you can't be there
i can't call you i can't
i i truly i understand that they
they're about to go through a really
hard time again and again i don't want
to take him away from that at all
are you going to miss your brother so
much
yeah are you scared for him to go
a little bit yeah are you scared for
their marriage in a relationship
um
not really i mean not scared for it not
that it's gonna break up but that's just
gonna be hard right you know your
brother's gonna be in pain right he's
gonna hurt
yeah absolutely and so rest in that that
means you're awesome
and that doesn't mean that you fail it
doesn't mean you're a loser that means
that
man there's a lot going on and you did
the best you can sleep with a sound
heart and mind
you reached out and you did what you
could and that's that
does that make you lonely yeah does that
make it hard yeah
do you need to get other people in other
deep relationships in your life yeah
but it doesn't mean you failed something
that doesn't mean you're a loser that
doesn't mean that you're not worth
anything
that means you didn't want your
casserole and quite honestly he might
want your casserole maybe he doesn't
want to impose on you
and maybe his way of showing how much he
loves his little sister is to not let
her get hurt
or to not let her be mushed up into all
this
and it may just be showing up
or it may just be honoring him and say
cool sending him a letter
sending little gift bags to those kids
and doubling down on hard relationships
are going to be in your circle and
around you
and in your local environment
the sucky part of relational risk is
that sometimes it doesn't look like you
want it to look
and it's hard and i wish i had a pat
answer for you i really do
kate i wish i could just say oh just do
these three things
that's not how relationships work but i
do think stepping back and saying did
you try to reach out to your brother you
did man you tried to love him good for
you
but also stepping back and saying i've
had two relationships two friendships
over the course of my 24 years you sound
like a really kind person
you sound like a gifted person but you
also sound like a person who guards
himself very carefully
you sound like a person who is very
giving of themself
but is really hard when people don't
want that particular gift and that's
okay
but i want you to work really hard you
may have to get with
a counselor you may have to get with a
pastor that you trust get with some
folks
and
oh man i don't want to say this in a way
that can be heard
you've got to get yourself in a place
where
you can take relational risks and you
can enter into spaces
not for the roi of i want this to be a
long-term thing or not a long-term thing
but i just want to be with you because
you're a person
i just want to go somewhere and laugh
and be silly and goofy
my brother's super busy with all those
kids i'd love to spend time with them
they don't have time right now
that hurts it does it sucks let's go get
tacos
i'm gonna meet some people at my local
whatever and that's hard right now i
know
i'm gonna be intentional about being
around people who think differently than
i do and maybe believe differently than
i do i'm gonna be intentional about
diversifying my friend groups
in hopes of just meeting different
people because i have something of value
to give
and it doesn't feel that way because i
reached out i doubled down on my brother
and he said no
but man taking a vet who's about to be
deployed with little kids
and absorbing that as something that's
about you is not is not fair
it's not fair to you it's not fair to
him that's not a signal of your
relationship that signal that somebody's
in the middle of a hurricane right now
and they don't need or desire your
support right now and that's okay
go to the next brother or sister go to
all the brothers and sisters
and also sometimes we just get rejected
and i wish there was a nicer way to
be around that sometimes people just say
i don't want i don't like you i don't
want to be around you
that particularly hurts when it's your
brother or sister i don't think that's
what's happening here but
sometimes we just flat get rejected
sometimes our friends just disappear
sometimes we have to call and say i'm
sorry but sometimes we have to look in
the mirror and say am i somebody who's
judging other people
we have to look in the mirror and say am
i hard to be around am i tough i don't
think i am
am i and maybe ask some of your other
brothers and sisters
am i hard to be around am i annoying are
there things about me that aren't great
the thing about my buddy who's staying
with me today over the years of our 20
25 year friendship
and he's told me hey dude you're not
cool when you do this this was not funny
you thought this was all silly and goofy
wasn't good he holds me accountable
and it's hard to hear but also helps me
become better
better person better man better dad
better husband better friend
so it sounds like you're just grieving
and i hope you'll grieve i hope you'll
just say this sucks
but i also hope you're not going to
internalize this and that you will risk
relationship you'll
risk love you'll release risk going out
and finding somebody else again because
you've got stuff to give
and your love is worthy of being
received so thank you so much for that
hard call kate i just can hear the
heartbreak in your in your voice
and um i hope you will continue to risk
on relationships
not brothers and sister relationships
but risk on hard relationships where
folks don't owe you anything
and they just want to be with you
because you're you